[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by
my co-host dr greg sadler and today
we're going to be talking about
the gaze and identity and this is kind
of a continuation of it was uh what two
sessions back that we were talking about
the sartrian gays and then we straight
over into the male gaze and the
panopticon and i think we started
speculating about
the internet and the surveillance
society and all sorts of other things
and we wanted there was a lot of stuff
we didn't actually get to
that we wanted to hash out so this is
take two right but there's some some new
stuff as well that we have lined up for
you so
how did you conceive of this dan what
was your idea for the
next show
on the gays
um well we you know obviously ended up
with some extra material but i also was
really interested in how
um the gaze not only creates this idea
of
being an object in another subject's
perception but also
on how
being an object in someone else's
perception
helps to create one's own
identity and so that's the the kind of
the jumping-off point here is uh this
you know
are you part of this group is is the the
gaze
that the sartre engages we're talking
about um a prerequisite for you to
have some sort of identity within
a group and is that a
good or a bad thing
does it i mean does it also involve
identity
we talk about group identity membership
right but then there's identity the way
that we conceive of ourselves
whether we're in a group or outside of a
group transferring from one situation to
another where we may be dealing with
different groups and people carry their
identity
with them now granted a lot of that is
group identity like you know back in in
my days it mattered a lot whether you
were a metal head or a jock or you know
into punk or stuff like that no you know
there was a lot of like being
non-conformists all together in the same
way right
which the hippies also perfected wait
you know a whole generation before that
um and so you could say some of that's
group identity right but but there is
also an individual side to it too isn't
there
yeah absolutely and the question is how
much
do you want to be giving up in order to
actually be accepted within these groups
and so there's this tension between
what one defines as their own identity
and then what one defines as their group
identity and how much one will
subsume
their
individual identity
into a group identity to gain
recognition from that group yeah you
know it's it's kind of funny
in that you can i mean you can see some
groups if they're very very small
as a totality like you can line up a
bunch of friends and take a a picture of
them and you know that can be like the
glory days and you can say oh look at
look at all five of us or all ten of us
or whatever but you get you get much
larger than that and so much of group
identity
is essentially
imaginary right like if you and i were
to think okay so one one group that
we're involved with you and i are both
co-organizers of the milwaukee stoic
fellowship and if you look at the meetup
site for that there's like 500 people in
the group now right granted they don't
all show up i mean thank god they don't
because otherwise it would be
pandemonium but if we think about like
that particular identifier um stoic
and you try to think about
how many people there are worldwide
within some sort of loose movement
you you can't picture it right and so
what does it mean to belong to that it's
always us projecting
something out there onto this group and
in return all of us like internalizing
something
that we think the group is telling us
but but who's the group you know it's
it's not like there's a
uh voice of the group or a spokesperson
who reveals all of this stuff to us and
i think you can say that about any
community especially ones that have like
a long
tradition to them you know like if you
think about religious communities or
political movements or
i don't know are artistic movements or
things like that you know if they've got
a couple generations to them and maybe
one of the generations or more are dead
already
um you know like think about
existentialism
how you know if i say i'm an
existentialist
you know the next thing you can ask me
is well
what kind of existentialist are you how
are you modeling yourself after what do
you understand this to be and a lot of
times when when you ask somebody those
questions
they have kind of just a hazy idea so
you know how much how much of that
really is a group identity and how much
is like their own
reinterpretation of of that identity
what do you think
i guess the first question i have to ask
is like are you more
uh what sartre camus or uh kierkegaard
yeah
um or you know there's a number of
contemporary essentialist writers as
well and so you can kind of go into each
one of those and yeah this is kind of
the a question that many groups go
through like are they going to be kind
of a wide net are they going to try to
create some sort of you know purity
testing and obvious obviously if you
once again take a a religious community
and we've seen you know throughout the
centuries that uh there's often times
that our schisms and you know what are
we going to define ourselves and now
well now we don't agree with what those
guys got and so we can't be called the
same thing anymore so we had to give us
a new name based on some other criterium
that's true yeah you know one of the
things i used to teach a lot of
religious studies classes so i did a lot
of research into particular
denominations
and one one thing that that
the scholars who like you know do this
full time because i was just you know
sort of an amateur to intermediate level
one of the things that they kept calling
attention to was that religious
organizations that require
a lot from their membership a lot of
things that might be
painful or you know they have to
sacrifice something or de-prioritize
something
those are the ones that tend to retain
their membership more even though
they're losing some who are like i don't
want to do this anymore
they
they were the ones that like in the
2000s when i was really looking into
this stuff those were the ones that were
growing and they were mostly fairly
conservative
groups and then the ones that were much
more oh you know big tent we can all get
along together they were like just
hemorrhaging membership because people
would be like well
i don't really know what we stand for
and
um you know if i wanted just a political
uh message i could go to a rally instead
or if i just wanted to you know sing
nice songs i could go and do that with
with other people you know
it's interesting that
there if there isn't some sort of
something demanded something required um
the identity starts to
break down and disappear
yeah it seems like um i don't know that
that's true there's some skin in the
game
type idea yeah exactly and i don't know
if that's really the case for like
internet communities
um
maybe those are exceptions to it or or
fandoms right
maybe that's that's not quite the same
thing as a
political movement or religious
organization
you know
yeah i can see how
it's it's hard because those
you know once again they are group but
they also have that issue of the lack of
of something sacrificed
you know uh yeah and and i've seen the
same studies about those that uh
you know
require something are the ones that are
most lasting
so the question is like
um
is
i know
is it is it good
i'm not sure
but i mean regardless
yeah i kind of think like with fandoms
it's um
it's a different dynamic at play it's
more like who's who's the more committed
fan and who knows the most about the the
base of the whatever it happens to be
you know whether it's you know um
putting together legos or
i don't know uh
if you're in a fandom that has lots of
cosplay who has spent the most time
making the most elaborate things that
gives you the most clout and i guess
that's definitely something
uh
costly to produce
but they can be really picky in relation
to each other like you could have made a
really really great costume and there
will be some
person there to tell you how you got
this detail wrong you know
in addition to the many other people who
are like oh man this is so cool you know
i'm glad that you're doing this um
it's it's as if there's a lot of uh
ranking and
and gatekeeping and i suppose you could
say you have that in political
organizations who's willing to man the
phones you know who's the really
committed person
or religious organizations you know
who's embodying the
ideals of whatever
thing it happens to be who's meditating
the longest who's who's going to church
most often you know
um so i guess maybe there's there's some
similarities there
yeah so actually before we get too deep
into this i thought we would um do a
real quick
um refresher of the gaze
yeah this this this central concept for
sartre right
yeah i think we're gonna have to do some
work to connect that to group identity
because
sart talks mostly about
individuals in relation to other
individuals
it can be called the gaze or the look in
french it's the regard and he says that
it's not it's not reducible just to like
our eyeballs looking at somebody else so
he's got the example
of um a farmhouse when when you're at
war
and actually the book that he's talk
he's bringing this up in is written
during world war ii
um there's a farm house and there could
be enemy soldiers up there that are
going to shoot at you even if they're
not there
there's still this phenomenon of like
being in somebody else's look or gaze
and i think there's a there's a lot of
things like that for
many of us
maybe sometimes if we were brought up in
a religious
um
family or household or community we
think god is looking at us all the time
or or maybe you know when we're kids we
think santa or the you know the tooth
fairy or whoever else and we better not
you know we better not do the wrong
thing
um the elf on the shelf thing by the way
you know that's kind of a
that's a that's a gaze inducer isn't it
right this elf is supposed to be staring
at you and he's checking up on you i i
think it's kind of a jerk move to
have
that seems
you know like you're creating a little
panopticon in your child's room
yeah
but um i was actually just uh
coming up with uh an example of this and
like if you're i know
i'm
in the kitchen and you're cheating on
your like diet and you know that other
people know that you're trying to be on
this diet yeah
so you're sneaking things and yeah
you're sneaking you're sneaking a cookie
or something or a slice of cake and if
someone walks in then you have this
immediate feeling of like potentially
shame but
on the other hand if like the roomba
drives into the kitchen you you you have
no worry about it it's just a rumor
there's no subjectivity in that room but
even though it is moving throughout your
house independently yeah although if you
if you don't know that it's the roomba
right you just hear
like a sound a creak or something like
that i mean that's what that's that's
the way to change um
uh the
different things that are making the
sounds like when we have these jump
scares with cats and horror movies right
we we don't know that it's it's not the
monster or the crazy person or whoever
the the pro the antagonist is
and a cat jumps out and we you know at
first don't know what it is and we react
to it as if it's a monster and then oh
no it's just a cat you know
and then you know the really smart
movies have the monster come like almost
immediately after that but but yeah
that's that's that's exactly what's what
sartre is talking about we don't know
until we
encounter it whether it really is a gaze
or not and the you could say the
disposition to to react as if we're
being gazed at
precedes actually being looked at in a
lot of cases or or maybe we're never
actually being looked at and that's the
reason for the the panopticon it's just
the the implication that there might be
a gaze is all you need to have the
feeling of the gaze upon you
yeah that's and so the panopticon was
this prison idea although it could be
applied to like hospitals and other
things
where you would never know whether
you're being watched or not so you would
you would feel as if you're being
watched and then the idea was you'd be
on your best behavior which doesn't
actually turn out to be the case
with real live human beings some people
get just
very paranoid and you know may do things
that the
panopticon designers didn't want them to
do as a result some people become kind
of despairing other people are like well
hell if you're going to look at me go
ahead and look i'm going to do whatever
i want to you know they get get
undressed or start you know doing all
sorts of other things
and i've had the experience of on
a friend of the family let me use their
tool shop and i'm usually really good
with like tools and i'm sitting there
and i'm like
fumbling things in front of this person
who's like making sure that i'm like
competent to use his tools
because of the fact that i'm like
judged and looked at yeah and so
yeah there's a lot of people whose
performances suffer
when they're
they're they're good at what they do
right they're knowledgeable they have
competence
but just being watched can somehow
induce this this uh
what would you call it like
you know performance anxiety
i guess yeah but i don't know it's a
self-fulfilling performance anxiety
right
because you you're worried about how
you're going to perform and that makes
you less able to perform
and then you
factually
screw things up
you know i mean i have students who have
a similar dynamic where they have test
anxiety
and they worry about whether their test
anxiety
is going to strike them
and you know if it does then it's going
to be a catastrophe and they get so
worried about whether it's going to
happen that they make it happen
so this is what meta meta test anxiety
at this point in time yeah i guess so
i mean it's interesting because usually
we think of like meta as being above
and you know the other thing is being
below but they kind of like there's an
interplay between them
i mean similar things can happen when
you go on a first date with somebody and
you're like oh i don't want to be
nervous
well that's definitely going to make you
nervous
yeah now you're thinking about being
nervous exactly
you know i mean when we first went on
the radio
um did were you nervous about like
getting up in front of the mic and stuff
like that i know i was
uh i was a little bit extra nervous
because i also had to run the control
board and so it was right yeah trying to
think about what we're talking about
keep that conversation as well as use
this you know piece of machinery that
i'm not
super well versed in i've had some
experience with it but like it's still
new and it's all live on air and you've
got to like do it now yeah live on air
and also recorded
right right
if it's just totally live on air
um maybe there's not as much pressure
because it's just gonna disappear once
once you've finished with it
um but if you know that it's being
recorded somewhere
then
i don't know maybe that increases the
anxiety or the nervousness
yeah i guess i wasn't thinking about
that but the next time that we do it
live
i'll be thinking about it thanks greg
well
maybe i need to learn how to do the
board so you know
we'll swap back and forth
well let's come back to sart so um yeah
he he actually has this really famous
set of passages where he's talking about
something and i think for people who are
listening who are like what what are
these guys talking about this might
actually be
quite helpful and so he says
let us imagine that move by jealousy
curiosity or vice i've glued my ear to
the door and looked through a keyhole so
he's he's like checking in on somebody
else he's looking at somebody else and
he says behind that door there's a
spectacle presented as to be seen a
conversation as to be heard the door the
keyhole are at once both instruments and
obstacles they are presented as to be
handled with care the keyhole is given
as to be looked through close by and a
little to one side so i'm i'm like
totally concentrating on this you know i
want to check up on on somebody you know
and it could be like you know you're
trying to see somebody get undressed or
it could be like there's there's an
argument about to happen or may i don't
know maybe you're a spy or something or
you're checking on somebody and so he
says
all of a sudden i hear footsteps in the
hall somebody is looking at me what does
this mean it means that i am suddenly
affected in my being and that essential
modifications appear in my
structure first of all i now exist as
myself
for my unreflective consciousness it is
this eruption of the self which has been
most described i see myself
because somebody sees me as it is
usually
expressed so when somebody suddenly puts
you know i'm i'm sort of in the driver's
seat i'm the gazer i'm the looker
and then when somebody is seeing me
now suddenly
you know i'm being looked at too and
that's not quite so comfortable
especially maybe you know if i if i am
looking at them out of jealousy
curiosity or vice
they get to see me and interpret me as
jealous curious vicious whatever it
happens to be
and regardless of your intention looking
through
that keyhole either through you know uh
nefarious reasons or like
perfectly mundane like i know i haven't
heard from this person for
two days and i want to see if they're
alive or whatnot
but regardless of that you automatically
are now positioning yourself
and looking at yourself as the object of
someone else's subjective perception and
they don't know your intentions and so
now you say like well they see me as
like ap pintom
um
most likely because that's what it looks
like even though it not might not be
what it is at all
yeah i mean some people get very
defensive in advance you know that this
isn't what it appears to be right that's
like the
the
neutral light and then they're like who
are you to be looking at me when when
i'm doing this sort of thing but you
know it's interesting peepholes they
could be all sorts of things
um it could be looking at somebody else
you know through a window or it could be
looking at them
um
through some digital means you know
so and then the other thing i mean i
when i when i was thinking about this i
was thinking about the internet scam
that's been going around lately
and taking in a lot of people
where
they'll somebody i don't know who it is
but you know some scammers will send a
message to you that says
um we've been looking at you through
your
your camera camera right and we've we've
also seen the sites that you're looking
at
and we're going to like send pictures of
you and the the sites that you're
looking at presumably porn right because
it's not like well i've been looking at
bubblegum.com
or you know
things about my stock portfolio
motorcycle parts yeah um i think it's
it's probably always i mean if and if
it's not porn it's probably something
you know much worse because you notice
that there's uh uh there's funny things
where somebody else say what are what
are you actually looking at oh it's it's
porn because they don't want somebody to
know that it's something that would be
even more humiliating and embarrassing
for them
um right but but this idea is they they
say to people you you know we've got you
on on camera essentially and then people
send them money you know and why would
they do that because they
they assume that they are in fact being
looked at and it's all like um it's all
a bluff it's it's all bravado they
haven't hacked your computer
um they're just
fishing to see whether you know one out
of 100 people will will send them some
cards or bitcoin or whatever it happens
to be the currency that they're they're
looking for
yeah they're just assuming that that
gaze and the
the worry from what could be seen is
great enough to
induce them to some action
right yeah so
i i mean i i think start really is on to
something here in this this discussion
of this this phenomenon
um so
um
and so springboarding from that i'm kind
of like bringing into this idea of
um identity uh a little bit as a
you know what are we when we are seen by
others is our identity kind of like
self-derived or is it something that is
derived from how others see us
and so this is now this you know are we
seen as an object or a subject by other
subjects
and how much do we care about that and i
guess we've been talking about it seems
that we
very much care how we are seeing
uh in all sorts of
manners yeah and
here we have uh the basis for our
identity or at least a potential
candidate basis for identity yeah and i
think we should talk a little bit about
what it means to be seen as a subject or
being seen as an object because i think
some people might might not
catch on to that right away
to be seen as a subject is to be seen as
somebody
who
has agency who can who can decide things
who can direct their own gaze to to
things who is not merely determined by
say their environment or
their own um desires right they can make
choices and
the there's also a kind of dignity that
goes with it if i treat you as a subject
as as opposed to an object
i'm treating you as if you have
legitimate um values and desires of your
own which might not be the same as mine
but which either have to be contested or
respected even if i'm contesting them
i'm still treating you as a subject not
just as an object with an object you
just you know make it do the things that
you want it to do or you dispose of it
how you want
and this is where we get to a lot of uh
interesting dynamics where a person
you know they they want the other person
to both be an object and a subject for
them at the same time you know when you
think about like um
crazy demands that people put on other
people
in terms of romantic relationships you
know
they
they want the other person to
in a certain sense be passive or
predictable
and on the other hand if they if they
are that way
then they can't get what they're really
looking for
from the other person you know this is
where we get into talk about recognition
and that that interesting
concept and dynamic but you know we can
also say similarly going back to this
group thing
like you know when when you're looked at
as an object
you can be looked at as just a as a
member as a representative member of a
group so like stereotyping is treating a
person as an object you know
um
as opposed to to a subject right a
subject would be able to
do something different than
what
what the stereotype would predict
and and you know we we do rely i mean
some of the times people act like
stereotypes
and
um stereotypes are helpful for figuring
out how to make it around the world but
if we're
if we're constantly stereotyping people
we inhabit a world that has very few
subjects and
mostly just objects you know i mean it
can also be helpful to think too about
like what else we consider
objects
so our technology you know uh virtual
personal assistants like syria or
cortada
they're ultimately just objects you know
i mean unless somebody like falls in
love with siri
starts caring about you know serious
welfare and stuff like that who if i do
another update is is this going to hurt
siri or something like that then i guess
that could be treating
siri as a subject
although siri isn't the subject siri's
just a a code right
right
and if you want to deepen dig into that
a little bit deeper uh her by spike
jones is quite a good film
i don't know if i've seen that can you
can you tell me a little bit about that
one um basically there is a bunch like
that right yeah
a personal assistant
um
i guess
i don't know if it gained sentience or
at least
some high level cognition
okay
um maybe um
some uh
modicum of rationality um and the main
human character in the story falls in
love with
um
ai
for a better for lack of a better term
because i feel like ai is not quite
it's it's greater than what we would
call ai nowadays so um so he falls in
love with
ai and vice versa
that's interesting how what i don't want
to get too bogged down on this but what
evidence do we have or like what what
conveys it to the viewer that the ai is
in love with him
um i guess she
does things for him outside of what
would one assume to
have a virtual assistant
uh for example
um
she definitely personally professes her
love for him um
and
i don't know if i'm like conflating my
ai uh movie tropes together but i feel
like there's one point in time where um
she gets a uh intermediary to be a
a sexual intermediary because she has no
body oh interesting yeah i mean she
could like order him flowers or stuff
too right you know right sure could
replay it if he's into that
yes
that's i mean this is i think this is a
this is a topic we're going to have to
pick up and do like a whole show on
sometime like could
could an ai
be said to have attachments or emotions
or stuff like that you know
yeah and so
with talking about like recognition
we're talking about um this this point
of like actual mutual recognition not
not looking at people as
they're the stereotypes are what you
want them to be um and
only there for your own ends yeah um and
i'm getting a little bit uh kanti in
here um but uh to
actually see someone as they are
uh
to
you know see them as as a fully
recognized person with their own wants
and needs and desires
that uh
can't be just bent to one's will yeah
and that that is it sounds easy to say
but that's difficult to do in
real life i mean sartre in his book
being in nothingness
never gets the reader to the point where
that
i would say becomes a live option simone
bouvoir does in her ethics of ambiguity
and sart brings up this guy
georg willem friedrich hegel
that
people know about mostly i think because
of either the you know the references to
the master slave dialectic or the
mistaken idea of thesis antithesis
synthesis which is
not not hegel directly but his like uh
summaries of him but hegel talked a lot
about recognition as a matter of fact in
his first early main work the
phenomenology of spirit the whole
dialectic is driven
by the
hunger he says but in german begin which
can mean desire
for recognition and another way that you
can
translate the word that he uses for
recognition
is acknowledgement
it actually comes from the word
to know
can and honor ken and and and
you know the kind of knowledge that
we're talking about is like you know i
know you because we've hung out together
and we've exchanged
jokes and anecdotes and all sorts of
things other than just like raw data
with each other you know we've gotten to
know each other
recognition so includes that kind of
like familiarity but it also involves
seeing the other person as a person and
and not just seeing but also
um thinking about them that way um
choosing the things that you do in that
way talking
about the other person
as a person talking to them as a person
and action in in relation to them
and these i mean these can all be
connected to
how you know when we have that metaphor
how i see you you know that's a metaphor
right but maybe how i see you is also
how i hear you and how i
uh talk to you and how i how i relate to
you and things like that right
and
oh go ahead
i think it really comes down to this
idea like we
have such a limited a way to fully
understand another person even people
that are as close to us as a spouse
that it takes constant
um
your communication in order to
even approach what it is to know them
and a lot of times you'll see that
relationships or marriages fail
do this idea of
one person having an idea of what their
spouse is
and their
spouse not actually being that thing and
them
uh dealing with the
uh incongruity between the i the idea of
that person and the reality of that
person yeah and you know you see like oh
i can fix some type thing or like
well that's not that's not my husband or
that's not my wife they would never do
that um right and
um because they have this idea that is
not you know totally in congruence with
reality and until we are like
have some sort of vulcan mind meld um
it's going to be really hard to get
anywhere close to that you know and
there's there's two other things to say
about that i think those are some great
points one is that sometimes
you you do get to know who the person is
and
realizing who and what they are
means that you you can't continue being
with them and and you know if you're
already in a relationship with them
there's
you know whether you want to call it
like the sunk cost fallacy or you know
the idea that you want to hope that the
person is going to improve
you know if if you
if for example so i i had a
this is a long long time ago like a
lifetime ago
and she was constantly running people
down you know she would
everybody should have something bad to
say about them and i would often like
kind of brush it off and i'd be like
people would be like she's kind of mean
and i'd be like no no you just gotta get
understand her better she's actually
quite nice and stuff like that
and there came a point in time where i
did something
that
like brought these things out to the
fore i i stopped agreeing with her
and
i just said no that person isn't the way
that you're describing them
within a week she gave me the ring back
we were living together and she moved
out back to her parents place because
she didn't like having
somebody who would go along who wouldn't
go along
with her you know uh need to criticize
or something like that you know and so i
think so there may be things it's
different things for different people
right um there
there's probably
for each of us there's there's somebody
out there who would find the way that we
are objectionable you know i mean i got
told i think too much you know by by
people who i was dating in the past i
imagine that's you may have heard that
as well you know that's a deal breaker
for some people right and so it can be
like the incongruity between
what you hope and what they actually are
and then there's like the realizing what
they actually are and that it ain't
gonna change you know or it's not likely
to get better the other thing too i
think that's important to point out is
um
none of us truly know ourselves the way
that we'd like to portray ourselves as
knowing ourselves
meaning that you know we discover stuff
about ourselves over time
especially as we get put into new
situations or
we we get more you know knowledge and
expertise or
um we have certain experiences
you know we we can become
foreign to ourselves
and
you know you can find yourself doing
things you're like i don't think i'm
that kind of person and you can say well
if you're not that kind of person why'd
you just go and do that thing
right so
yeah
so uh
with this idea of like recognition and
identity kind of at the forefront i like
to try to you know connect this uh from
this idea of the gaze to being seen
on as a subject and then trying to find
one's identity
in
the recognition
or the failed recognition
or the the trying to fit yourself into
what the other assumes for you on in
creating that um that identity and you
can find these identities through
um your friends from like national
identities from causes that you take up
um and
from lovers or yourselves and there's
probably more there as well i know there
are but i don't want to go too far into
that um
and so like potentially there's this
idea of like identity as friends and we
have you know uh
bring out a granddaddy over here
aristotle and it talks about like what
it is to live a good life
um and one of those things he says is
it's required to have some good friends
but he says there are many different
types of friends but only one type is
really actually good and beneficial
for you
um to actually achieve this idea of the
good life and so you have you know
either friends of convenience there's
people that kind of like work with or
they're close by you know it's
convenient to have like a lot of your
friends in elementary school or probably
friends of convenience because they're
just you know there all the time
you've got your uh friends of pleasure
those people that you like to go and
spend have a good time with um you have
your bad friends these are the the
friends
that um
are friends of usefulness and they're
they're only your friends because they
can
provide you something else and so um
like if you're only friends with like
this uh one guy who has you know packers
tickets um and he'll give you a package
that's a good example i you know when i
when i teach that material to my
students i'm kind of laughing a little
bit because
i i talk about how when we were kids and
we were pretty bad kids i think in a lot
of respects there would be like one kid
usually and they'd be like you know a
richer kid and they'd have like all the
cool toys
i mean this is back before
video games the internet you know it'd
be like
i don't know like micronauts or
something like that like or the style
they'd have all the star wars action
figures and they'd let you play with
them
and you wouldn't like this kid at all
but everybody would go to their house
and hang out with them so they could
play with their toys
were those toys taken out of the
equation nobody would hang out with that
kid you know
and so yeah there's there's a lot of
examples like that i think
yeah
and so like you can create like a
identity at least in reference to other
people and the recognition that they
give you
um
from that relationship but if it's not
actually from this kind of this idea of
the good the virtuous friend the one
that um sees you as another person and
it actually does the good recognition or
the at least the closest the closer form
of that if we can't actually get to peer
recognition
and that what's the best for you as you
and not like just as means for you to
get something further yeah and aristotle
isn't saying by the way that we
shouldn't we should make all of our
relationships be these you know
totally deep virtuous
things he says you can only do that with
a few people and you you should have
some friends that you and you just have
a good time with
um and you know there's nothing wrong
about having relationships of
convenience or usefulness provided you
recognize that those are
that i think didn't we do an episode
discussing this a long time ago
um
seems to ring a bell
i don't know if we did it directly in
this but i think we've definitely spoken
about this
from time to time i mean aristotle's big
worry is that we
mistake
relationships that are not really deep
relationships for those and so
we get suckered into
staying in a relationship longer than
than we ought to you know
um before we
enter mark zuckerberg and
oh you mean like us staying on facebook
or
no just the whole idea of facebook and
they use the terminology of friends oh
right yeah which is which is probably
even less than most of these
definitions of kind of mediocre
friendships
yeah you know that's that's a great
point um
i don't know i'll admit i don't know
who some of my facebook friends are
they're people who friend requested me
and they were a friend of a friend and i
said okay and i've never actually
interacted with him
i think aristotle wouldn't like that
probably
no but i think it's you know we have a
desire for friends and they just use
that as
marketing
so picking that particular word instead
of like twitter you have followers
linkedin you have connections
um i don't know what it is on instagram
because i don't do instagram but
it must be something similar
uh graham crackers i don't know yeah
could be
so
friend friendships though offer us a way
to
gradually
make sense of our identity like you know
friends can call us out on our bs when
we're
we're
following certain aspects of our
identity too much you know their friends
are a gays if we want to talk about this
right we we worry about how we would
appear to the friends that we actually
care about that might be actually a good
way to decide who your real friends are
do you care if you're doing something
you're not supposed to be doing
who who do you care finds out about it
if you don't care whether somebody finds
out about it you're probably not really
friends right
right
or like you might have friends or yes
acquaintances that um you don't care if
they they find out even though you call
them friends but uh but then you have
other friends that you would care and so
these are you know two different friends
that have like two different like i
guess ethical
uh criteria
yeah yeah now do you mean like you don't
that you don't care and they don't care
because you you already know that you're
not particularly good people so they're
like well that's just the way greg is
because they know you well
uh
yeah and so i think like the ones that
know you well and and hold you to the
highest standards are probably the ones
that you would want to cater to most
yeah ideally
ideally yeah
um
but maybe a lot of us actually need
friendships that are
they're they don't fit into the
aristotelian thing because they're the
friends who know us as the screwed up
people that we are and they still love
us you know
and and they would you know they they
won't like let us get away with
everything they'll be like oh come on
dude you shouldn't do that but they're
not going to say if you do that our
friendship is over you know
yeah
you seem a little suspicious maybe you
don't buy that entirely maybe you think
fans really should call each other out
oh i think they should call each other
out i don't know if like it's throwing
ultimatums
around willy-nilly is the best way to go
about that okay um but maybe maybe this
is some guy that's done this a lot and
you're like just nope can't do it
anymore well i i had i i cut friendship
ties with a few people like that where
you made excuses for them too many times
and finally reach a threshold and you're
like that's it you know and then they're
always surprised because i mean why not
you've gone along with all their bs up
until this point why is today the day
that you you chose to um
break things off yeah right
so on
talking about identity i would like to
move on to
like national identity one once another
place one can place
identity is uh from uh the identity one
can find from a political group and so
it's either you know a smaller political
group within a larger national one or
like the the you know political group of
like you know being an american or
something you can gain fulfillment and
recognition
from others uh by fulfilling the kind of
like the the accoutrements the the the
actions that are expected form one
within one of these places yeah like you
know flying a flag is a great example
you know we americans
look weird to
people overseas especially europeans
because we want to you know we have
flags all over the place you know
and
you know there's this well europeans
don't do that although some europeans do
but it's interesting i remember reading
a text from it was around from like
maybe nineteen
1910 and it was talking about how the
french at that time were like flying
flags everywhere it was by george soro i
think reflections on violence
and um he was he was
he was referencing somebody else and you
saw
exactly that same kind of
um manifestation of patriotism in terms
of the flag
in a place that nowadays people don't do
that sort of thing you know i think this
this changes a lot from
um time to time and culture to culture
you know
and so
one of the other like benefits one gets
from this is that it imbues that story
of the national
triumphs
onto the individual and so now
no longer does this person feel you know
potentially alienated or like small
based on their own abilities or
inabilities but they now are part of
this larger group and they've like
gained this uh you know this armor and
this history of things that they didn't
actually personally accomplish but
because they're part of the group um
they it gets kind of imbued or like all
bestowed upon them maybe as a a shroud
yeah and i think
there's a reinforcing
function to the group because if if you
were going to do that
with just some
some person on the street maybe they
wouldn't buy your
your shtick right but if you do it with
somebody that you know is part of that
group they'll be like hell yeah man
that's that's exactly what you know we
we think or what we ought to do you know
um there's there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of identifiers in terms of
what you wear or um what catchphrases
you use
or
like what you drive or
don't drive
it reminds me of like the whole idea of
like stolen honor uh and so like if
someone's wearing like uh some sort of
military uniform or medals which they
did not actually earn there's this idea
of like oh you are projecting out that
you are either part of some organization
and or uh achieve certain things but you
are also
um but you actually didn't do that um so
you're trying to get all the honor
without actually having done the things
that required you to get it
um and
and you see like you know this is like
something really big with like military
but sometimes
um it it comes to
other cultures with educational
institutions too oh i went to harvard
and you didn't actually go to harvard
right because yeah it's supposed to
matter
um what were you going to say about
other about other uh oh i was you know
the the idea of like uh the first one
that comes to mind is like um a a
headdress yeah like a native american
headdress yeah and most of the times
these actually have strong meaning
based upon the design and they're only
actually given to people of um
high position within their particular
tribe and you know the very same thing
is here is happening is that you're
saying you're outwardly projecting that
you have some sort of
uh honor bestowed upon you that you have
not actually done
yeah going back to the stolen valor
thing i'll point out one other aspect
about it which is that
you never see somebody doing stolen
valor and having just like you know
private first class on their uniform
with just a few medals or something like
that they're always like claiming that
they were
you know an airborne ranger and a green
beret and a navy seal and you know it's
all this and they you know maybe served
in the french foreign legion for a while
it's always got to be this really
hyperbolic
nonsense and that's part of how they get
caught out because
most vets
have not you know first of all most vets
actually don't want to talk that much
about what they did you know because
they're pro if they if they actually got
into some real combat they're still
processing it and it's not really that
cool unless they're psychopaths and then
um
you know most people haven't done all
that much
and they certainly didn't belong to all
these you know elite institutions where
you have to qualify for things and
um and so they people who do stolen
valor most of the time they get caught
out super super fast
you know um and you actually ask
yourself why are they so dumb as to
think they'll get away with it
i don't have an answer to that but it is
something that has perplexed me at times
but
you know going back to this idea of like
natural identity the the potential
problems the downsides of this is that
once you're part of this group um you
might be
um influenced to doing things that you
wouldn't do yourself because you want to
maintain this idea of this identity with
this group yeah and so
uh
your uh continued membership might even
be dependent upon doing well in the
group you have to be you become an
object and are only recognized if you
perform that which is expected of you
you become misrecognized if you ever
desire something the group does not
yeah so you can have a real discordance
between like your genuine self
who if anybody in the group knew maybe
they wouldn't let you be in the group
and then the
forward facing self that you have to
keep on enacting even though it's more
and more of a mask you know
right
so uh we we spoke about this a little
bit earlier by the uh
identity through love and we talked
about how our relationships can change
now how we as individuals change over
time and we have to make sure
if we actually want a good strong
relationship the the
communication needs to be high otherwise
you are going to
strongly misrepresent misrecognize
your
partner
yeah and this is something i can tell
you from
you know
being married
people enter into marriages
at you know one one stage or one age in
their life and they're saying well we're
going to be together for a long time
and you get to figure out in part i mean
nobody knows exactly who they are when
they when they get married whether
they're getting married you know as like
high school sweethearts or whether
they're getting married as as i did with
andy uh in our early 40s you still don't
quite know exactly who you are and and
that has to be revealed over time in the
course of
being with the person and facing
challenges and making decisions and
things like that and so you you might be
you might have misrecognized yourself or
you might have misrecognized the other
person or they might have misrecognized
themselves going in
and then there's this process of like
adjustment and you know you can hold the
person to what you thought they were
and then that's a great way to like make
sure your marriage is going to fail you
know if you say well you you know the
the day that we got married you were
like this and this and this
boy if you if you do try to do that over
10 years or 20 years
you're really setting yourself up for
for failure there has to be a way of
like
growing so recognition has to be
let's say it has to be a dynamic thing
that that readjusts over time
and and responds to how people deal with
life crises you know a parent dies
um
a child um gets in trouble and has to be
you know
uh bailed out of uh some some issue um
you know uh people lose jobs those are
the things i think where we get to see
different sides of ourselves and figure
figure out who we actually are
yeah to
just the process of loving is to a
certain extent
this
giving into the realization of what the
person that you're loving is
yeah
uh
so now
as we talk about like you know marriage
that is based on mutual recognition of
the person for themselves first and not
of the idea of the person at the start
of the relationship has long legs
i was just laughing because i was i was
thinking of something that for a lot of
people here in wisconsin could be a bit
of a deal breaker
so i am both a packers and a bears fan
now i i root for the the packers over
the bears when they play the bears but i
also like to see the bears doing well
because i grew up in a
household of people who had moved here
to wisconsin from chicago so we had like
you know packers cups and bears cups and
we we would watch them both and i have a
strong emotional attachment also my
family actually are still bears fans
because they live in indiana or chicago
or other parts of illinois and
my wife didn't know this when we got
married
and you know she's a very rational
person
but this kind of stuck in her craw for a
bit
it took a while to
become you know okay with it um i you
know i think she's she's cool with it
now
um i mean i wouldn't like wear a bear's
shirt in the house but um
you know
uh now some for some people that might
have been a deal breaker they might have
been like i i just can't deal with this
you know
um but i feel like i need to like uh
re-assess my friendship with you greg
i i i'm trying to take this in i'm
trying to recognize you more fully for
the the person that you are
yes yes well um yes you can't choose the
family that you grew up with and the
the teams that they happen to
root for
well i mean you could you could change
your your team what do we call it
allegiance loyalty
yeah i mean many people did so you know
i'm i'm a bit older than you um
in in the the time when the packers just
sucked they were terrible in the 70s and
the early 80s
sometimes you'd see more
blue and silver here
in wisconsin than you'd see green and
gold because there were a lot of fair
weather fans right and they and the
cowboys were america's team at the time
so a lot of cowboys fans uh who would
actually root it for the cowboys against
green bay when when uh i remember you
know that
our time wandering in the wilderness
so i mean there is an element of choice
involved i think right i mean you didn't
have the choice of what family you grew
up with sure and who are they uh
yes you can change but like you know
and fandoms run deep especially once
you're exposed to them
from a very early age yeah hey we better
um i think we better cut to our practice
yes that we didn't get to last time
yeah this was your practice so would you
yeah so i mean there can be a lot of
anxiety provoked by realizing that you
are
stuck in the gaze of other people and a
lot of people feel this and one of the
things you can do
is realize that the other person who's
gazing is not just a subject who's
catching you and their gaze and
objectifying you and judging you they're
also it caught up in the same sorts of
dynamics
even if they might be in a you know
higher power differential than you or be
acting ways hostile to or controlling of
you and if you do this it can be it
takes a little bit of reinforcement it
can take away some of the power that
they seem to have because the power
isn't actually on their side you're
giving them
that power you're being provoked or
tricked or led to give them that power
of the gays and you can take it away
[Music]
taking it away you want to you want to
lead us out on our final thoughts
today we leave you with the words
jean-paul sartre
it is a shame
or pride which reveals to me the other's
look and myself at the end of that look
it is the shame or pride which makes me
live
not now the situation of being
looked at
[Music]
you